all right so welcome to chess in the
Romantic era again for those in the
YouTube channel my name is pepper cuenca
I'm Anna Spanish Brown Master glad to be
here with all of you and again I would
like you to participate in the class so
questions comments etc everything is
welcome so what are we going to talk
about today well I will be talking about
the evolution of chess in the Romantic
era I see you guys know in the romantic
time from the 15th century to the 19th
century people playing chess were very
aggressive they only care about
attacking the opposite game opening
files and sacrificing everything but
they didn't care much about prophylaxis
positional play etc etc so to talk about
this evolution during the Romantic era
I'm going to talk about Paul Morphy do
you know who was Paul Morphy yes right
so he was a great American chess player
he had a brief but a brilliant chess
career he quit chess very young but
during his period he was considered to
be the best player in the wall all right
so he was from from the States but he
travelled to Europe to play the best
players in the world for example
Anderson or low and tile or Stoughton
even though he didn't manage to play
against Alton because stout on was given
a lot of excuses and finally didn't have
a match but people considered that Paul
Murphy was the best chess player in the
world in that in that time so to talk
about this chess evolution first of all
I'm going to explain you the structure
of the class so in the I'm gonna show
you two positions or two games from Paul
Murphy where he finished his opponents
in a spectacular way and then I'm gonna
show you two games where
one can see that they didn't care much
about prophylaxis or precision of play
of course we always talk from the
deepest respect we have for them and in
the final two games I'm going to show
you the evolution of chess from Paul
Morphy so it was probably the first
player who influenced the way we played
today so his play suffered a revolution
so he started to think about strategy
and strategical play prophylaxis etc etc
okay so this is the first position that
corresponds to a symbol he gave him in
New Orleans in 1857 and he had the black
pieces and he was a really strong player
in tactical play so as you can see both
players have two minor pieces two rooks
and one Queen but white is three pawns
app likes to play and if you do nothing
you're going to lose
yeah so because now your knight will be
for its attack so let's try to think
about how you finish your white opponent
in this position okay and I always talk
about the forcing moves in order to talk
tactical to solve sorry tactical puzzles
you always have to take in account
captures checks on threats so let's
start with the checks for example you
what's your name Kevin tell me how many
checks can you give him in this position
yeah so Queen h2 is a check right but
that doesn't look very good
right Knight f3 is a check not to go
because of G take stripe and then what
else the other check 92 right 92 so we
got three checks we got captures as well
right so tell me how many captures you
see in this position
I see two not three three we take said
sure it's the right same what else
rook takes c3 and group takes c3 and
rook takes e4 okay is any of this move
have any sense for your make any sense
rooks III doesn't make any sense right
but looking for is interesting we need
to finish to it yes terrible yeah but
looking for is very interesting and in
this foursome move method after one
capture again you have to go on in the
process and then try to compute all the
checks captures and threats can you
thread something ruk ruk h8 is
threatening checkmate but after h3
nothing happens right
you saw the solution yeah I mean you you
you found it yeah okay let's wait for
the others so what's a beautiful
combination more feet saw this man tell
me amazing
yeah like g3 you are threatening
checkmate right or almost a checkmate
because 92 is really strong and then the
thing is if white takes on 87 then you
finish finish it exactly 93 - checkmate
yeah so this is what morphe found in the
board in a symbol not an easy task
right so take Tony 420 XC 493 if white
takes 23 then twin takes e4 right and
then blacks winning right so just two
positions to show you how strong he was
in these types of positions okay so
let's go to the next one and then
whoa let's put this training mode
alright so morphe had the black pieces
in this position he's Epona
you know this game yeah okay yeah I I
went through your YouTube channel so not
to repeat some so much thought because I
know you saw the evergreen gain the
opera game so I wanted to do something
different from this lecture so blacks
upon app but it's not clear at all so
why play Bishop III rook b8 and long
castle and it looks like it's not that
easy to make any progress right in this
position because c5 is not easy to play
because yes D takes e5 right Kevin and
then what would be your plank having in
this in this position with black how
would you try to to make any progress
yeah do you like that movie should take
six - no right because the bishop is
paid there then okay yeah okay use you
said the solution but we have to see
which one works the move that Paul
Murphy found in this position what was
group takes F - a brilliant move because
after Bishop takes F - there is a
brilliant continuation Kevin tell me you
said you soil rugby - and then if I just
take it some food for free for me
we need freaky anyone win keen egg one
sorry Bishop b4 okay but even though if
I just played Bishop II one take and
take and then I have two rooks and one
and two bishops and you have one Queen
and one Bishop so what is better no
problem
you're doing good let's go back this is
the key moment where Morphy found
another brilliant continuation we need
three checks captures and threats can
you thread checkmate in this position
maybe it's not easy to to to to find
Queen III but you follow this method
forcing moves method let's let's thread
checkmating one of Queen III make sense
oh it makes sense because black what can
take on a tree because there is
checkmate them after Bishop a3 right so
Queen a3 brilliant move by Paul Morphy
the thing is you can't take on a tree
because of Bishop takes check me but why
still can't define the position how you
offend the position quincy 3 all right
quincy 3 the problem is what's the
problem
Queen a2 or Bishop f4 right Bishop f4
only move root D - and then you can just
take for example on a - right
so after Queen a3 the most natural move
to to defend this c3 exactly and Murphy
played Queen a - what's the threat now
he wants to go Queen a 1 and Queen B -
checkmate
right so different alternatives are
white for example why could try to go
Queen c2 now after Queen a one day skin
D - and then the King escapes so how do
you feel is right now yeah yeah Bishop
f4 exactly and after rookie - there are
several alternatives but for example in
fries yes very good and black is winning
so in the game okay white plate B 4 B 3
is just not possible because of Bishop
III right checkmate
but before was played and Murphy
continued with Queen a one teensy -
Queen a for King b2 was played and now a
big boom
Kevin think like more free sacrifice
everything open lines kill the opposite
king
come on Kevin you can do it I know that
sacrifice everything
open lines sorry a five
it's the idea is correct do you want to
open the B file right Abby
exactly well well played
we should be for what's playing see
takes me for rule text before and
basically White has to sacrifice the
Queen or the wife steps there's gonna be
checkmate on b2 for example in c1 win a
1 and after King C - Queen B - checkmate
right ok so white had to go for Queen
takes me for Queen takes before king c2
and another great move by Paul Morphy
this picture is doing nothing right here
is a handsome Bishop is doing nothing
right
how will you bring it into the action
addy Bishop a5 is interesting the idea
is correct you want to keep some check
but now for example we should be free
and blocks this diagonal so III first
you win the temple and then this Bishop
is coming with a check so takes takes
and then white have to resign few moves
later
for example after Bishop d3 what would
be what would be the killer move okay
you saw that rap again for C moves
checks captures and threats let's keep
some checks we need four is one check
tell me all the checks Queen C 5 is a
check and then Quincy 124 yeah so maybe
you don't imagine this move but as you
go step by step analyzing all the checks
you will find a solution right so you
can use the mathematics just step by
step
yeah methodically so Quincy for just
points a game you can take and then
after King goes you just take the bishop
on d3 and then white has to resign right
all right so okay the game continued III
Bishop takes rook d3 Queen c4
kimby to check on a2 and then the rukon
h1 was hanging under Luke indeed free so
Edward Henry Edward Byrne had to resign
ok this is the second position that I
show you to see how strong Paul Murphy
was in in these kind of positions
alright so let's just try to analyze his
witnesses
ok not this position the next one 3 ok
this game was played between Murphy and
La Venta in London if I remember
correctly in 1858 it's what it was his
first match against a tough opponent in
Europe and then after this he went to
Paris to one of the cafes before in this
century chess was played in cafes there
was no there was no son who is chess
club and there were no chess club's but
people used to meeting in cafes to play
chess and in this position Paul Murphy
played f6 and now as I told you Paul
Murphy was a really aggressive player so
taking that tonight a conducting in
account what Murphy played in this
position with the white pieces
now that you know morphine addict
thinking like an attacking player what
would you play here with the white
pieces
Bishop eight-six maybe that's too much
right no the idea is correct you wanna
take you want a threat Bishop h6 so in
order to threat Queen g4 exactly you are
thinking now like Paul Murphy the best
player in the 19th century
alright so they were obsessed with
attack yeah but this is not the correct
move in the position because you have to
think about prophylaxis what does black
want to play here so black would be
extremely happy if he could exchange
these two bishops right there would be
no Bishop h6 and then you could use the
D file to exchange some heavy pieces
right so Daniel what would you play here
with the black pieces exactly correct so
this is precisely plaques idea c6 root
d3 and Bishop c5 and suddenly White's
attack doesn't have any sense because
now you can take on eight six because
there is a pin so Queen g3 roopd eight
and everything got exchanged and then
white hadn't any trouble actually
loewenthal won this game in some in
endgame later but the point is
prophylaxis is very important in chests
not only trying to kill your the
opposite King right so now that you know
that blacks plan is to play c6 and
Bishop c5 how do you stop that okay you
know you know Kevin knows rat keen each
one in each one is interesting but can i
play c6 anyway where you want to go root
D 3 and then Bishop c5 right sorry
Bishop d2 yeah okay that's possible but
now you see that black has developed
well and then he is planning to exchange
some pieces yeah route d3 is still there
is some attack right
let's say maybe cleaning seven and Queen
f7 something like this but there is a
much more effective way of stopping c6 a
be perfect now you have played better
than Murphy so roopd one was the best
move in this position it's some of this
place we're not used to play because
they were only thinking about attack
attack and opening files okay they
didn't have the tools we have today
giving half chest base they didn't have
database with games to check right they
had to create their own positions for
sandwiches and they didn't have a genes
engines sorry
so look everyone is a brilliant move
because now black can't play c6 the
thing is a lot went out to try to go
route 88 in order to do the same stuff
but now how do you stop against a6 Adi
perfect perfect win d3 and you can see
that now black can barely move his
species meanwhile we can play c4 a 3 B 4
threatened c5 and then black is never
going to be able to play c6 and there is
a lot of pressure in this position for
black so I told you see for p4 all these
moves are coming and then black is in a
lot of trouble so this was in the
correct way of playing but he went for
24 and then he got nothing all right I'm
gonna show you another position this
correspond to a game between daniel
habits and morphine dining habits was
one of the best players in that period
again
and here this is an isolated composition
they were not really experts in this
period in these types of positions and
at this point white played Bishop g3
really natural move you don't want this
Bishop to be captured by the knight on
c6 and can you tell me natural moves for
black here in this position yeah Bishop
d6 Brooks CA Bishop f6 all natural moves
exactly Kevin give me another move
f5 you were thinking like morphic
aggressive play but do you see that fi
has a problem right the pawn on e6 you
don't want to blunder it so the other
reasonable move could be Knight f6 right
very typical in these types of structure
in order to put pressure on the d4 pawn
in order to give this Bishop free
diagonal right so rook c8 Bishop f6
Bishop d6 maybe have the same problem as
what happen in the game because Bishop
f6 Knight d5 he takes d5 and now this
bishop is clumsy so the diagonal is
closed and then c5 is going to be a weak
squared
so after this Bishop are trade off then
some group can end on c5 and then this
Bishop is much better than the Bishop of
b7 right but in the game Paul Morphy
play teenage shape I really strange move
right
because they were aggressive players he
wanted to go for sure f5
he loved to advance the f5 pawn but in
this position that doesn't make any
sense right because f5 is actually never
possible because the e6 pawn is hanging
so in this game rook e1 Bishop f6 he
realized that f5 was just not a good
idea yeah so Bishop f6 tweeny for
attacking on h7 threatening checkmate g6
nack takes good move by harp it's
closing this diagonal for the base of
ambition
Queen takes Queen takes and naggy five
and then they reach this position where
now you can see that white is much
better
you just have to realize about the
difference between these two bishops and
then White has the to open files the c-5
square and this bishop is just basically
doing nothing yet Kevin you like this
bishop on c6 no right doesn't have any
diagonals so it's a terrible bishop
so morphe ended up losing this game the
key moment is this teenage shape move
that doesn't make any sense now we're
going to go to the next game where
morphe start the revolution of his
office of his play and then maybe the
revolution of chess because he started
to think about prophylaxis positional
play and maybe was the first player who
did that and then who influenced the way
we play today what wait not we but the
top players we blunder everything I
planned everything to Kevin so let's go
to the next game where one can see this
change and he start to play like the
hyper modern school the hyper modern
school was built let's say 70 80 years
after he died so do you know what were
the principles of the hyper-model school
exactly so the classic thought that you
have to occupy the center with your
pawns but the people from the hyperbole
in school for example reiative they
thought that you can give up the center
but you can you can control it from from
from some distance let's say with the
fee on Cato bishops and then you can
attack it right you can strike on the
center with your pawns for example the
groom fell let's I'm gonna show you
what's a groom for the groom fo d4
Knight f6 e 4g six nights if the next
III d5 you can see that after E for 93 B
takes c3 why this in control about all
the center right but black is going to
put a lot of pressure these are ideas
from the hyper modern school you're
gonna play Bishop d7 g7 sorry c5 96 and
all your pieces are striking in the
center right so the next game that I'm
gonna show you Paul Morphy plays like
that and he went this game basically
doing nothing not brilliant attacking
sacrifices but only thinking about
positional play and I'm gonna show you
this game which is very very interesting
so efore was played c5 d 4 ok 93 96 this
can transpose to the normal order right
by the way Kevin if black plays a 5 what
would you play with white would you take
that pawn are you sure
YY exactly we need 5 check and then
takes on in fact right ok but you can't
just play C 3 and then there's a lot of
compensation a lot of weaknesses and
white is living in development so all
right so we reach this Sicilian b5 you
know the name of this defend our D
anybody knows lo one time you have the
name right there Lowenthal he created
this defense it's very very interesting
here morphe didn't play what's
considered to be the best move nowadays
the best move the 95 right aiming to go
for the wigs squared e6 sorry yeah
exactly
but it's not the same order right
because in in this world championship
match they normally 96 94 9 f 6 Knight
c3 and then e 595 d6 we have seen this
opening like six times in the World
Championship match between Fabian Marco
Scott's right 95 this sorry yeah this is
the Pelican you guys know that Bishop g5
is the main idea the mainline sorry but
bobby was trying to win with this Knight
d5 which is very very interesting okay
so II five straight away this is the
Lowenthal Knight takes c6 okay this is
not considered to be the best move
because now you are given black some
Center right we take c6 and now black is
in good shape because it's controlling
d5 anyway it's perfectly playable Bishop
c4 native six and here the most natural
move maybe is Knight c3 controlling d5
protecting if or but Paul Morphy played
short cut what do you think about this
position you think it's okay to take on
e4 do you think it's a bad move
do you see a way to lose okay okay we'll
come to that you can take it yeah okay
94 it's a good move but the point is
what do you play after rook e1 d5 and
then okay still it's not the end of the
world because now you saw the way you
can lose right after D takes e4 Bishop
f7 just wins on the spot
King e7 Bishop g5 still you can play
here D takes e4 you can take yeah rookie
5 we should be 6 and then why this a bit
better but okay at least you don't lose
the game yeah after Detex afford you
lose the Queen so but the simplest way
of playing this position just Knight f6
and after Brooke e5 which would be 7 we
need to you could be scared about this
move but after d5 there's no trouble
you're going to put your picture on e6
and then you're going to go short Castle
right so let's say Bishop d3 and you can
even try it Knight g4 here there is no
proper square for the rook maybe you
have to go to h5 or something which is
which smells bad kidding right
so yeah but long went off got scared and
he went for D 5 D 5 looks natural right
so you control the center but then
Murphy it's gonna play like the hyper
modern school people say I'm gonna
attack the center with all my pieces and
he did that and he won the game I'm
gonna show you how so good take on d5
whoop take on d5 now it should be 5
check yeah Bishop d7 yeah we need to is
also possible but I would say I can play
Bishop d6 and yeah but it's also a
normal move but he took on d7 and then
he attacked the pawn on e5 with a more
most not with the most natural piece
with the rope right so rookie ones is
more natural
yeah rook e1 Bishop d6 and now b55 is
possible you have to choose we have to
attack the center so we can play Knight
c3 or Bishop g5 or c4 c4 I'm just gonna
collect the ball and then ask you what
what you wanna do next c3 ok but I'm
gonna go short castle and then drop on
down you have to justify what you did
and here I don't see a clear way Knight
d5 ok it's interesting but a place I can
just play Luke 88 even though if you
captured the pawn on c4 you've got
nothing right this is completely equal
so so now let's just play natural moves
how do we attack the center you have to
choose between Bishop g5 and Knight to
c3 exactly yeah and there's a concrete
reason because if you play visual d5 the
move is 94 exactly 94 when in a temple
this night is not pin so you have to go
back and then maybe I can play Queen e6
or something and still looks good for
black the point is after Knight c3 is
not easy to protect the d5 pawn Kevin
what would you play with the black
pieces here d4 and then Adi
punish punish Kevin for what he did
look at this skin on the center exactly
perfect we take see 400 kV not what
so after 93 you can play d4 Bishop c7
and now it makes sense what you guys
were saying before so Bishop g5 now
there's no 94 and basically I don't see
a way of defending the pawn on d5
maybe group d8 or something like this
but this smells really really bad even
Bishop f6 Queen and free and then Brooke
d1 looks really good for white right so
Murphy thought he was much worse here in
this position and then he started to get
a little bit crazy because it was not
easy to defend maybe the best mode is
queen is six now that I think about the
position but it's not a natural move to
put the Queen in front of the group
right maybe we can even continue with
Bishop g5 and then put some pressure on
the center still and then this looks
very good for white in the game
Lowenthal played efore and now can we
capture on d5 are you sure y-yeah so
Knight d5 is just losing because of
Knight takes d5 Knight Queen takes d5
from Bishop h2 and then you win the
Queen so what do you play here having
them you don't take them d5 you want to
take with the Queen on d5
so how do you increase the pressure on
the 510 g3 with this move you are
increasing the pressure on d5 you want
to put your kin safe yeah
teenage one all right
like more feet to push the f1 okay okay
that's yeah now you will be threatened
to take on d5
I agree but looks dangerous for example
Knight g4 and then f2 is weak but it's
interesting the idea you want to take on
G on d5 there's another way of
eliminating a piece that defends the
five who defends d5 came the night then
exactly Bishop g5 do develop another
piece and then you want to take on f6
and then you would be able to take on d5
right
okay so Bishop g5 and basically black
can can do anything
so for example I don't know I I don't
even know what to say here's let's say B
should be 5 just take and then 90 XC 5
is just pawn up the e4 pawn is hanging
the king is still in the center you go
short Castle I win the Queen one spot so
very hard position for Lomita AB as you
can see Murphy hasn't done anything
special he just striking this has
tracked in the center and nothing else
right so okay lo and tau wanted to to
get everything messy and he went for
Knight g4 here and all right what would
you play here okay
Murphy took on d5 Bishop takes 8 to key
in each one the rookin a8 is attacked
right so black has to do something about
this he took on d5 Knight takes d5 and
now you have threatening different stuff
you are threatening the pawn on e4 a
fork on c7 and
more f3 right so basically black can't
handle in everything he went for sure
castle and now Adi egg three perfect and
this is how Paul Murphy won the game in
16 moves vs Levante one of the best
players in the world he did nothing
special right but it was a change in his
play and a changing in the play of the
players in general so takes takes 95 and
then rocket free III was played after
Bishop d3 f4 just went on the spot so f6
Kimmage - yeah
sorry g3 g3 probably it's also winning
let me think about it but for example
now would be tougher for you to capture
one piece for example after f5
you can't keep my net from G for my pawn
on e4 is protective probably you're
gonna play King g2 and brocades one and
you'll get two pieces for the route but
it's not a free piece with f3 you win a
free piece right Adi 9300 brilliant yes
93 exactly it's also wins good Kevin
yeah Bishop takes on f4 right f4 yeah
Bishop takes rook takes f4 yeah you
don't win so much material as in the
other variation to win a free piece just
go for it so this is this was a game
between more fiallo and tough and I'm
gonna show you one last game which is
one of my favourite games it's very good
from the positional point which is wrong
point of view and here okay White's turn
so for example here sure Castle f3
Knight of 2 but then all right but then
the bishop on h2 is hanging oh yeah
that's the point so you kick this night
whatever wherever this night goes I'm
gonna capture this Bishop on h2 alright
okay let's take one or two minutes to
think about their position so Murphy is
driving the the black pieces against
heartbeats heartbeats was considered to
be one of the best players at that time
this match was played in Paris in Paris
France the move
and morphe okay let's just try to
analyze the position morph is attacking
with the black pieces with a queen on
edge for the rook on 86 and it's white
turn sorry yeah he always moved there
for me so what would you play with the
white pieces here first of all what do
you think about this night on b4 it's
it's in danger it's a good night yeah
it's almost red doesn't have proper
squares - JA right it's doing basically
nothing yeah so what would you play with
the white pieces you give me the camp
candidate moves so Adi one more sorry
efore okay they just try to mark them on
the chess board before what else
95 okay sir I move for white here all
right Kevin a three something else yes a
three Carla okay what's the trick you
wanna give me check mind already
okay the thing is this attack is not so
strong anymore right because whenever
you go Queen is to a queen each one is
just King just runs into f2 and then
this queen is attacked so whenever you
go back to h4 I can't even cover with my
queen on g3 or I'll kind of give and go
back to g1 right okay
if four is a bad move why because if you
go F takes e4 Knight takes e4 why black
wins on the spot Queen is we need to
followed by Luca for right so II for
it's not a good move
also this Bishop is doing nothing even
though if you take with the rook on e4
right to stop rook F for this Bishop
can't come back to c8 and then it will
enjoy a good day Alan so not a good idea
to play if for in this position then
what else okay just all right where are
black witnesses in this position see
what c7 okay a 787 okay these are quick
pumps but weak squares ecigs also f5 is
upon which is not total weakness right
it could be a witness or potential
witness so the knight on c3 is
well-placed
or it can be improved can be brooked
right so for example one of the best
moves in the position was 92 in order to
go to d4 putting pressure on f5 and
going to e6
Harvick's play a three it's made it the
first move that comes to our minds right
we think that this night has to go back
to a6 and then what would you play with
the white pieces here a db4 but has the
position of the night improved of the
Black Knight or it got worse it has
improved actually because after Marcus
moved nag to be a the knight is much
better here sorry
down here because now in two hoops it's
attacking so
this is very natural but it's helping
black and more free probably five years
ago something he would have gone crazy
and trying to try to go for some g5
attack in the black the white skin but
he started to play positionally and he
went for Nagbe a slow maneuver intended
to go to f6 and then to g4 to cut the f2
square for white skin and then threaten
some checkmate on h2 ok 98 was played
and night e 2 now Harvick's realizes
that the best square for 90 MV fourth ok
let's try to think about prophylaxis
Group g6
what are you stopping yeah so white
plans not to go to g3 with the knife
because doesn't do anything there sorry
c5 it's a brilliant move it's a very
good move
ok morphe didn't play c5 he went for 97
maybe much more natural intended to go
to f6 but c5 it's a brilliant move
because it stops the knight coming to d4
and if white takes on percent then this
Bishop comes to life yet alright so c5
very good move 97 was played and here
heartbeats played 93 he followed Carla's
idea he won he was very scared about
blacks attack and he wanted to go Keon
f2 and rook h1 and tried some rooks but
maybe here the best move was Queen g3
after Queen 8 5 then Knight to d4
putting pressure on f5 and after I don't
know something like g6 96 and white
could be better
right but instead he went 1493
and now g6 was played by morphe and keen
f2 he was obsessed with the blacks
attack and he wanted to exchange a pair
of rooks Knight f6 was played by Murphy
rue cage 194 check King g1 Queen f6 the
one I've landed your Queen rook eight
six and nine eight six and we reach this
position where this Knight took a long
journey from be four to eight six it's
so tired now alright so Queen D one was
played and Knight to g4 black wants to
go to 84 with the Queen Queen t2 and
Queen h4 by Murphy you want to go Queen
h2 and take the night so prophylaxis
knife one you can't take my knife and
also you can't give me cheap chicken on
h2 right
Ruki a good move putting pressure on e3
g3 and queen it's free I'm here Harvey
it's what scared maybe a little bit
about the move c6 right because maybe
you wanna break with c6 and try to give
some fresh shirt with this Bishop if
this Bishop manages to enter in the game
would be very dangerous for white right
so what do you do to stop c6 be queen G
- okay Queen d2 doesn't stop c6 because
after the trade of Queens you play c6
and then maybe you're in a bit of a
trouble yeah take stakes and then
suddenly this Bishop is really really
good but be 5v5 stop c6 and I like very
much the way Murphy played the rest of
the game
so b5
yeah okay he went for Knight f6 put in
an eye on the e4 break and also as you
say now c5 is is a white square and then
I don't see five would be very very well
placed so Murphy
sorry harvest decide decide to go for
Queen g2 and this is where I see again
the change in his play because five
years before he would have gone Queen
eight six to keep the Queens on the
board to keep attacking his opponent but
he saw a way of playing the same game
after queen g2 king g2 how you think he
played in this angle a6 what do you say
a six having 97th Kevin Knight g4 okay
94 the problem of 94 maybe white can
strike in the center with E for 97 is
very very interesting again maybe white
can't strike in the center with E for
yeah 9 e4 you can but the thing is maybe
I can exchange now and then 92
protecting c4 and then when you retreat
your group then maybe 4 and these type
of n games the knight can be even better
than the bishop you don't enjoy a lot of
diagonals here and I think why this ok
in this position but a6 is a brilliant
move by morphic because you're gonna
opened the a file and this rook which is
okay here on EA it's gonna be much
better placed on the a file looking for
some active squares right
so a 4 was played it takes me five you
have to take with a pond right heaven
and now have it perfect rook e8
occupying the open files an ID to
Brooks e3 e4 takes takes takes Bishop
takes okay rook c3 was played first and
now Bishop f3 what do you play now with
the black pieces
Kien f7 or rook takes e4 you have to
choose between kin f7 is better because
if you take on c4 this drug is going to
get an active square on e7 the rook on
the seven-branched controls a lot of
squares and it's hard to to make any
progress yes
Adi
much better yeah actually that's enough
Ruki 18 f7 and group b 8 trap in the
bishop so you can't even take on c4
that's why he never 7 was played rookie
for protecting the c4 pawn and now the
only piece who is not active the bishop
Kevin you want to go to a eight or to
see a or to a6 c6
alright CA exactly yeah on e ed is doing
nothing on c6 maybe it's a gift for your
friends but on c8
right you want to go to f5 and then this
which way is much better here g4 was
played no sorry they played Bishop e2
after g4 h 5 is the move exactly pawn
takes Bishop f5 let's say take skin
takes rook before and rook d3 and then
you are forcing white to take on d3 and
then the c4 point is gonna fall
and later the b5 or the d5 pawn so
probably the engine is completely won
for black instead habits play Bishop e2
Bishop f5 route D 484 is hard to play h5
first stop in g4 and now keen f2 kin f6
group D 2 and now how do you continue g5
ok
d5 I guess I can take this guy here and
then stop that easy to make any progress
right like for example Mookie for
but yeah okay okay he's saying that it's
very interesting to go bishop be one in
order to go bishop a - okay it's really
not possible but the point is you remove
the bishop from the FI square to go with
your kin so in the game more if you play
Bishop C - in order to play kin f5 later
on or even be should be three as you say
putting some pressure on the c4 pawn
king a1 and Bishop b4
why not kin a5 Kevin kingi one was
actually setting a trap yeah white play
right to play in wins oh sorry
KYNA five Kevin follow our method for C
moves checks captures and threats and I
guarantee you're gonna win this game
think about captures what can you
capture oh you see great great route C -
you see this method is brilliant yeah
you just go step by step and then you'll
find a solution
take some Bishop d3 right awesome so but
with the King on f2 is not possible so
for example let's say if white plays Kim
G - and then kena five looks it -
doesn't work because there is a pin so
that's why King II want was setting a
trap now to see if Murphy play kena five
mercy marked mercy Murphy realize about
this and then he played Bishop e fourth
keen f2 and now we continue with keen f5
and what's black idea here after Luke a2
how would you continue
Adie
Bishop d3 but then all right I can take
and then maybe play rook a7 and you get
these gets very very messy because
you're gonna take my g3 palm but I'm
gonna tell your c7 at your basics and we
both start running and I don't know who
I write first there's no need for this
maybe it works but it's risky right
rooks e2 after rook C tool I'm not sure
sure if you can win this endgame for
example takes or even know okay Lucas
and Bishop e3 that's your idea but then
maybe I can just play King III here I
don't think so I can't just play Bishop
f3 we should be - or Bishop d1
I have three squares for my Bishop and I
don't see a way you progress in this
position right
okay so after root k2h for that's the
idea
brilliant so we keep advancing with our
kin so G takes and kena for and now
plucks idea is very simple you want to
go route a tree and then brook h2 and
keep keep moving
so root k7 was played grew cage-free
root c7 and now Kevin finished the game
Brooke h2 is very good because after
kini kini won
now that you have come from f7 you have
to keep going so exactly kini three
threatening the bishop on e to Bishop f1
and now finish the game
one more move you are there come on
perfect bouquet - and then route k1 and
habits had to resign in this position so
as you can see this was again where
Murphy improved his pcs slow step by
step playing positionally and this was
really impressive
by that time where everybody used to
sacrifice everything and attack from the
mood from from move number one okay guys
so this was the lecture above the the
evolution of chess I hope you guys have
enjoyed and thanks for coming
[Music]
you